well as we have been hearing the Wagner
group is active in a number of African
countries including Mali Nicholas hack
has just returned from there he sent us
this report from neighboring Senegal
the Wagner group is helping Russia
expand its influence on the African
continent it's present in over a dozen
countries such as Mali in the Central
African Republic where in 2018 I met the
head of the Wagner group in that country
he told me then that Russia is back in
Africa not that Wagner is starting its
operation in Africa he's alluding to the
Soviet Union's influence on the
continent tapping in this Nostalgia that
many have both in the Kremlin but also
among senior military official in Africa
such as in Mali or in the Central
African Republic where many speak
Russian or have been trained in Moscow
and this ties in with numerous visits of
Sergey lavrov over the course of the
Year trying to exert more influence on
the region as a war breaks out in Europe
and this has paid off with many African
countries uh not voting against
sanctions against Russia at the U.N
security Council and so Putin is
organizing on July 26 the Africa Russia
Summit but for the Wagner group its
presence on the African continent is for
profit it is present in countries that
are rich in gold and minerals in Mali
but also in the Central African Republic
where you control the endasima mine
worth up to 2.7 billion dollars money
that is used to fund uh the war efforts
or the fighters of the vacuum group away
from Africa on the European front line
and so it seems that the Wagner group is
a private Army that the Kremlin cannot
do without at least here in Africa
Nicholas Hawk Al Jazeera Dakar
I've been speaking to Colin Clark he's
from the intelligence and security
consultancy the sufan group he explained
the crucial role the Wagner group plays
for Russia in the international Arena
it's not possible for the Kremlin to
marginalize Wagner
Russia and and Vladimir Putin depend on
and in fact need the Wagner group to
carry out Russian foreign policy not
just in Ukraine but around the world in
Libya Syria the Central African Republic
Mali and elsewhere so this is a key
component of how Russia operates in the
world and I think this Rift has exposed
some real divisions in Russian command
and control and you know frankly it's
it's made Putin look quite weak people
that cross Vladimir Putin tend to have a
bad track record of falling out of
Windows in Russia we've seen them
eliminated uh with little Fanfare on
multiple occasions in very brutal ways
uh and if you look at the track record
of the way that Moscow operates and it's
not shy about attempting to or in fact
going through with executing Russian
dissidents abroad you know think about
Alexander lipanenko the scripples the
assassination of uh the the Chechen in
Berlin there's numerous occasions in
fact a recent story just came out about
the Russians targeting uh a former
Russian intelligence officer in the
United States in Miami so quite Brazen I
don't think Putin will shy away from uh
exacting revenge and punishing uh you
know pragosian if he if he thinks that
that's necessary and and I think he
probably will